[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Great whites
grow up to 20 feet long,
and can pack over
5,000 pounds of muscle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yet, despite their size,
they often go unnoticed.
A type of camouflage
known as counter shading
gives these sharks
the predatory edge.
They're dark on top,
but pale underneath.
So underwater, they blend
into the background,
whether seen from
above or below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But all that changes
from the air.
ANDY: All right.
Here we go, tethered
drone taking off.
NARRATOR: From high
in the sky, a shark's
camouflage can't hide them,
and their cover will be blown.
ANDY: Let's try to
find some sharks here.
NARRATOR: The best view of
what's below the surface
comes from high above.
Andy' drone scans from the sky.
And while down at
water level, it
looks like every other
day at the beach, the view
from above--
Woah, woah, right there.
NARRATOR: Reveals a
very different story.
A drone's eye view detects
an unmistakable silhouette.
Now you see it, now you don't.
ANDY: It's pretty incredible.
There's sharks everywhere
literally right
under the boards of
these people, right
under their noses, and
they don't even see it.
NARRATOR: Down at water
level, glare and reflections
can easily distract hiding what
looks obvious from high above.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY: I got a lot of
sharks in the area.
This is incredible.
NARRATOR: It looks
too close for comfort.
But are people in danger?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Despite Santa Barbara's
increase in shark sightings,
there hasn't been a
fatal shark bite here
in almost a decade,
a stat that today's
survey will help unpack.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY: Synchronize watches.
All right, great white
stakeout, here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, and 3,
2, 1, here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]